[Musica]
per me
momento questo ted particolarmente
emozionante significativo il di sicuro
perché sono tra amici voglio confessarlo
subito quindi è un momento particolare
un po nella mia città ma perché per la
prima volta vi racconterò qualcosa che è
stato per me un sogno un sogno che oggi
cercherò di fargli rivedere con forse
degli occhi diversi
e voglio anche raccontarvi quello che
per me può essere un nuovo sogno
partiamo da qui partiamo da quello che è
stato un secolo il ventesimo secolo
secolo straordinario seco straordinario
in tutti i sensi perché è stato un
secolo di guerre un secolo di grandi
scoperte di geni di scienziati un secolo
che ovviamente dobbiamo definire grande
ha condizionato completamente tutti i
modi di pensare di essere della nostra
contemporaneità è stato anche un secolo
che io mi son permesso definire semplice
ma perché in realtà è stato un secolo di
correnti di pensiero di ideologie un
secolo che ha aiutato tantissimo le
persone a avere una chiara idea di
futuro
idea che potevano essere in lotta tra
loro idee chiare idee rivoluzionarie ma
erano idee idee di di un nuovo futuro di
un modo nuovo di vedere il mondo
a un certo punto poi questo mondo fatto
anche di contrapposizioni
come dicevo prima un mondo che viveva
del bipolarismo uf6 urss
un mondo che a un certo punto si
sgretola con il suo muro si sgretola ma
le cose sembrano semplificarsi ma si
complicano terribilmente si complicano
terribilmente perché il sistema
economico diventa terribilmente più
complessi del sistema finanziario
diventa più complesso un mondo che viene
definito poi globale c'è un mondo in cui
i confini non ci sono più ma le
dinamiche ci sfuggono
e io non lo so se è una conseguenza
perché bellissimo poi leggere la storia
come un'allegoria fantastica ma non ci
sono non c'è una conseguenza logica
questo ma nasce un invenzione che ha
creato il dagli anni 2000 in poi ha
creato il xxi secolo nasce un invenzione
che da subito è stata definita distratti
ugualitaria un'invenzione che andava al
di là delle divisioni geografiche andava
al di là delle disuguaglianze sociali
economico un'invenzione che quella del
di internet che pensate che nel momento
proprio in cui è stata inventata e
c'erano più soluzioni tecnologiche che
andavano in quella direzione
il world wide web in realtà permetteva
anche rompendo una delle catene di
trasmissione di colmi di poter comunque
continuare il messaggio il collegamento
la trasmissione dei dati
fu questa la grande carattere innovativo
e non a caso fu pensato in un periodo di
guerra fredda in cui anche interrompendo
il legame seacom poteva comunque
comunicare il web
l'internet e parte credo del sogno di
tutti noi tutti quelli che l'hanno
vissuto è stato è stato il mio primo
grande sogno perché era un sogno come vi
dicevo prima sociale è un sogno che a un
certo punto la rivista wired italia col
suo direttore luna e cavalca tal punto
da dire dobbiamo candidare internet al
nobel per la pace
eh sì perché scrive scrive veronesi ho
preso un estratto di alcuni dei
tantissimi articoli di quel periodo
scrive veronesi se il web vincesse il
nobel dimostreremo gli osservatori due
cose che eravamo determinati a volgere
al migliore utilizzo nell'interesse
dell'umanità intera
cioè eravamo determinati a cambiare
l'umanità intera non si parla di
tecnologia qua si parla di umanità di
socialità di anche di economia
questo è il grande sogno che dall'inizio
del 2000 possiamo dire tutti hanno
coltivato riprendo appunto proprio
riccardo luna che scrive qualche giorno
fa non credo qualche mese fa
e scusate qualche giorno fa settimana fa
su repubblica proprio queste poche righe
che sono estremamente significative
il sogno diventa forse realtà per me è
diventata fortemente realtà quando dice
che in realtà in quel posto dove tutti
ci ritenevamo liberi e uguali
pensavamo una vita più umana e più
onesta si sono affermate delle
piattaforme delle regole di c'è un
modello di business oggi che usa i
nostri dati che ha tutto tranne che
l'uguaglianza e che forse anzi mostra
proprio i nostri lati peggiori
e successo così che il più grande sogno
forse la stessa penna che aveva
candidato internet al nobel per la pace
scrive queste parole così dure così vere
e io mi son dato delle spiegazioni
voglio raccontarvi un po quello che oggi
è la realtà di quello che è un mondo
della tecnologia
il sogno diventato mercato scrivo perché
pensate solo che le grandi piattaforme
nole bit tech vengono chiamate hanno una
liquidità che oggi è pari a quello di un
pil di uno stato come la svezia
potrebbero comprare tranquillamente uno
stato il debito di qualche stato hanno
una concentrazione di ricchezza come mai
si è vista nella storia economica
mondiale
e poi c'è tutto un tema enorme un tema
che conoscete tutti un tema fiscale
un tema attualissimo un tema molto molto
molto molto europeo come pagare meno
tasse
come non ritornare i soldi nello stato
in cui in realtà faccio profitto
eccetera eccetera
c'è anche un altro grandissimo tema che
oggi viene chiamato la gig economy si
dice molte volte banalmente la perdita
dei posti di lavoro per l'automazione ma
non è questo e molto di più perché oggi
i sistemi intelligenti come vengono
chiamati di intelligenza artificiale si
basano tantissimo ancora sul lavoro
umano ma un lavoro che viene
svalutato in qualche modo pensate degli
esempi della silicon valley che mi
raccontavano come per il riconoscimento
delle immagini e le fotografie con
l'intelligenza artificiale
bisognava avere bisogna avere delle
persone che abbinino le immagini e
dicano la macchina quello è un cane
quella è una macchina questo lavoro
manuale ed è ancora fatto dagli uomini
questa economia del digitale in realtà
sta portando a dei lavori poco
riconosciuti poco retribuiti e poco
valorizzante è un altro ragionamento è
questo anche molto personale quando si
dice il sogno distratti questo sogno di
innovazione grandissimo grandioso che
poi oggi in realtà
e molto meno vero le start up forse la
domanda è ma oggi potrebbe nascere una
google oggi un linux oggi c'è davvero
quella possibilità creativa distruttiva
o forse il mercato si sta condizionando
anche lo sviluppo tecnologico è
condizionato pensate questo dato che il
75 per cento dei venture capitalist e
supporta in america supporti
imprenditori di soli tre stati realtà di
soli tre città no che sono new york
chicago e san francisco
e non stiamo parlando di disparità tra
africa europa e america sta imparando
all'interno della stessa america dove
c'è il più grande concentrazione di
venture capitalist come in realtà sia
completamente this paritario per chi
nasce in texas poter accedere alle
stesse opportunità e credo ci sia molto
poco da dire su questo
ed è una constatazione che si è rotto il
sogno democratico che andrai analitica e
l'esempio che di cui è inutile insomma
soffermarsi è molto bella la
teorizzazione la nuova diciamo teoria
socio economica della zubov filosofa
sociologa il capitalismo della
sorveglianza finora assunto un piccolo
ho preso un piccolo estratto ma
il senso è che noi siamo la materia
grezza le nostre esperienze diventano
come diffusore finanziari le nostre
esperienze sono quella cosa da
condizionare da manipolare affinché può
essere venduta e più viene condizionato
il nostro comportamento e maggiore
ovviamente saranno i risultati economici
di profitto che i grandi della
tecnologia possono fare una violazione
delle libertà e poco è una distruzione
anche del sogno democratico perché
ovviamente sulla politica questo è un
impatto incredibile e l'ultima
considerazione è che dobbiamo metterlo
noi siamo passati da un idea di
democrazia alla prima più grande e forse
unica nella storia oligarchia l'e45 più
ricchi al mondo
non è un tema solo di ricchezza sono
anche coloro che possiedono convinceva
l'azzurro le nostre esperienze
condizionano le nostre esperienze oggi i
grandi della tecnologia non sono solo
quelli che hanno più soldi sono anche
quelli che possa entrano in tutti i
meandri della nostra vita sociale ed è
una cosa unica è una concentrazione di
potere unica e oggi bisogna dirlo
bisogna agire perché oggi c'è un
oligarchia tutti gli effetti
e allora volevo cominciare ponendomi due
grandi domande di cui sicuramente io non
ho non ho una risposta però sono due
domande che tutti noi adesso dobbiamo
porci la prima è come si può ritornare a
essere padroni di uno sviluppo digitale
a misura d'uomo ritornare a credere
quell'innovazione a misura d'uomo
definiamola sostenibile la seconda
domanda è come amplificare ovviamente la
voce della politica ma senza
assolutamente ritornare indietro cioè
senza frenare quella che è l'innovazione
l'innovazione digitale
ecco allora quando si pensano queste
domande
incredibili enormi di permettetemi di
sognare un cambiamento dello sviluppo
del mondo è molto difficile perché tutti
vogliono cambiare il mondo nessuno vuole
cambiare se stesso prima cosa seconda
cosa perché non sa assolutamente da dove
partire allora io però ho provato a
darmi a sforzarmi a dare una risposta
invitandovi però un'altra volta dire che
la risposta sarà data da tutti noi non
sarà data da una persona sola e la prima
la prima parte della mia risposta è
sicuramente che dobbiamo partire dalla
comunità dal locale
da qui perché ho voluto riportarvi
questa questa indagine del forum delle
famiglie che su un campione di qualche
migliaia di persone
alla domanda chi sono i vostri leader e
il 93 per cento trova il proprio primo
leader il proprio esempio da seguire
all'interno della famiglia e quindi
quando si pensa sempre dobbiamo trovare
il grande leader che cambierà il mondo
beh in realtà nel piccolo nella comunità
c'è tutto
proprio stamattina per caso forse non
per caso ho sentito insomma questo
documentario di come è stata fatta la
prima linea di metropolitana di milano e
la cosa fantastica è che il prestito al
comune l'hanno dato i cittadini stessi
milanesi milanesi hanno fatto un
prestito al comune perché serviva quella
sviluppo quella linea della
metropolitana del dopoguerra senso della
comunità che fa sviluppo e porto un
esempio personale non l'avevo pensato ma
la metro e la funivia della maddalena di
cui progettista è stato mio nonno
come tutti sapete qua a brescia poi si è
chiusa è stata la prima società ad
azionariato diffuso più grande dopo la
banca che sia stata brescia ed è stato
un progetto di comunità perché si voleva
oggi si vuole ritornare indietro ma si
voleva portare la funivia portare i
bresciani sulla maddalena questo senso
della comunità che crea sviluppo è da
dove è dove il primo passo dove partire
e poi c'è un'altra cosa che una novità
di cui l'italia dopo l'america è stata
la prima a certificarne l'esistenza e
società b corp
ecco da qui io voglio partire perché
quando dobbiamo pensare oggi a che cosa
effettivamente la comunità può fare
perché un'idea che non può essere solo
un'idea politica deve essere
assolutamente un'idea di progetto da cui
partire di progettazione
ecco allora c'è un modello oggi ci sono
queste società società benefit società a
profitto che però hanno un'unicità di
avere come obbligo all'interno dello
statuto il fatto di dover fare impatto
sociale positivo a un modello di società
che ha una cosa diversa rispetto alle
altri modelli societari che sono
riconosciute nel mondo è il primo un
grande modello societario e l'abi corp e
il marchio che contraddistingue che sono
cresciute che sono riconosciute in tutto
il mondo e hanno l'obbligo di fare
profitto ma ha impatto sociale
e allora pensate a questo concetto la
comunità la creazione di società b corp
che agiscano all'interno della comunità
e abbiano ovviamente una caratteristica
fondamentale che siano ad azionariato
diffuso
cioè che l'esempio che facevo prima del
di brescia ad esempio che facevo prima
di milano ritornare a essere padroni di
società che fanno sviluppo sul
territorio guidare noi l'innovazione
un'innovazione diversa un'innovazione
etica e allora permettetemi di elencare
tre punti principali secondo me che
dovrebbe fare questa b corp questa b
corp che appartiene un po a tutta la
comunità della prima cosa ritorniamo al
punto di partenza
quel grande secolo del novecento che
dava delle grandi e chiare o di battute
idee di futuro oggi ci sta mancando
stanno mancando idee di futuro ecco
dobbiamo ritornare a pensare ma non a
livello mondiale dobbiamo ri per tornare
a pensare nella nostra comunità a
scrivere a riflettere su delle idee di
sviluppo futuro come la vogliamo
la città come la vogliamo la nostra
regione come lo vogliamo il nostro stato
partire da qui queste di corpo devono
essere anche dei laboratori di pensiero
devono tornare assolutamente a dare la
possibilità nei piccoli territori di
pensare all'innovazione distrattive
libera devono dare la possibilità alle
start up di nascere di provare di loro
proof of concept di provando tutti gli
effetti di avere quella solidità e quell
aiuto iniziale per poter per poter
cominciare dare libero sfogo alla
propria creatività ma soprattutto devono
essere il vincolo ai fondi europei a
tutto quello che sta succedendo in
europa perché oggi non possiamo più
pensare a una comunità che non sia una
comunità locale ma europea
oggi noi dobbiamo avere un disegno d
europa un disegno etico di europa e
allora tutto quello che è europa deve
tornare nella comunità e ci vuole questo
collegamento non è solo un tema
economico ma è soprattutto anche un tema
di sviluppo di sviluppo futuro
l'idea di sensibilità e di nuova società
ecco che secondo me una una frase che
riassume perfettamente una fotografia di
quello che la nostra società oggi i
nostri tempi è una fase di marina
abramovic è un'artista contemporanea che
dice ho capito qual è il bisogno del
pubblico oggi che non è guardare
qualcosa ma essere parte di qualcosa io
credo che fare innovazione oggi non
possa più essere guardare un'invenzione
guardare a una scoperta ma fare
innovazione oggi essere parte
dell'innovazione grazie
[Applauso]